[Music]
so let's move on to our first theme so
when deep blue beat world chess champion
Gary Kasparov in 1997 it seemed like we
were on the precipice of being perhaps
even overtaken by machines but 20 years
on have we really made enough progress
to suggest the actual potential for true
artificial intelligence so the question
that I'd like to put to you all is what
is actually the nature of intelligence
and could this ever be found
in a machine and it so I'm very fond of
a definition of intelligence that Schoen
leg one of the cofounders of google
deepmind
after surveying a lot of definitions in
psychology he kind of converged on with
you that intelligences of ability of
reaching your goals in general
environments so general environments is
doing a lot of work here an Intel inton
is supposed to be able to play both
chess and learn a little bit of a basic
surgery or do anything else there it's
something that is a general
problem-solving ability assuming that
agent wants to do it now the tricky
thing is of course what we might set the
craziest goals for our software that's a
serious issue on its own another problem
is of course the total world of all
possible problems is so vast that we're
probably doesn't exist anything that's
more intelligent than anything else
fortunately this universe the surface of
this planet is a very specific
environment and there might exist
intelligent beings that can thrive on it
I think we you must or at least an
approximation to that so that means that
we might indeed be software that could
be generally intelligent the problem is
of course most of software we're writing
is not generally in talent at all it's
very good at one thing so we're getting
a lot of narrow AI and you can make a
fair bit of money from that so far you
haven't been able to make that much
money from general intelligence google
deepmind is doing some amazing stuff but
it's a very burning through a lot of
money working on the holy grail of
general intelligence while probably if
you were an investor I would say yeah
but I want something that makes me money
now worry at least in ten years
i picking up in your point about
operating in general environments i
think to be generally intelligent which
includes both emotional intelligence and
what will be more generally concerned as
you know things like playing chess well
you have to understand complexity we
live in an incredibly complex world all
of us operate you know here on this site
we are going to in the next few hours
interact in some way or another even if
it's only walking on the path with them
with hundreds of people all of whom
bring their entire life histories and
experience to how you interact on that
path as you decide how to get past each
other that's an incredibly complex thing
and you what i think is that what the
kind of thing we need thinking this sort
of approach we need to take his systems
thinking that brings in the kind of
science the rules that AI is good at but
it brings in a whole lot of other
understandings and it brings in
experience of you're actually good at
navigating past people on that path
because it's something you've done many
thousands of times before your body
knows how to do it you probably don't
consciously think about it at all and
that's one of the things that i think is
the foundational problem with AI is it's
not embedded in bodies in the experience
of being a lived body in the world and
it has to be and i'm going to pick up
what pick up on what david said and
disagree with him very fundamentally
because hey you know that's what one
does but defending doctors because i
think if we apply systems thinking to
ask why do people become doctors
yes doctors are quite well page but if
your motivation is money there are
things that are a lot better paid than
medicine are particularly three please
people become doctors because they do
care thanks Ashley
David okay well that gives me great
scope to answer the question just go
back to the first bit which is what's
being in telogen well I could say it's
being female for a start but apart from
that
there is the issue about we make a
sociation so the idea about computers
can potentially be intelligent they
crunch huge huge amounts of data much
more than the human mind at least the
male mind will ever be able to crunch
but there's another aspect to actually
being intelligent which is fallen out of
the frame recently which is about making
judgment calls it's about being able to
decide when to take a risk it's coming
to a verdict has come into a a diagnosis
and that's what intelligence is actually
about it's not just being able to crunch
data but on and this comes to crunch
point when you think about the caring
doctors should give when should they
take risks and I think they aren't
caring I think they go into an awfully
comfortable job where they're paid well
and the goal of status and they have
drifted into a kind of position at the
moment where the greatest concentration
of fake news on this planet centers on
the drug a doctor gives you almost
everything about an arm patent
pharmaceutical is ghostwritten and
there's no access to the clinical trial
data behind it now the pharmaceutical
companies are just doing what you'd
expect the pharmaceutical companies to
do they're in the business of trying to
have to you know to maximize shareholder
kind of well to maximize the value of
your the shares which is great they're
doing what they should be doing doctors
shouldn't be doing what they're doing
which is handing out these pills and not
challenging the data enough I'd be lack
of access to the data but also the data
that when happens when you come in to
them and say look doc this pill you give
that you just gave me I'm becoming
suicidal or notar I'm hooked to it or
I'm unable to make love on it they're
not seeing you and they're not listening
to you these days they aren't caring and
this is where they're not being
intelligent you know they're not making
a diagnosis they're not making a
judgment call they're not taking a risk
and it's not particularly in
because if they don't do this they're
going out of business because they're
high-cost
prescribers and nurses and pharmacists
will be cheaper and are they're
replacing doctors now and in the near
future will be replaced by robots anyone
directly to so one point here so you say
the doctors need to have a critical
attitude to the information we're
getting that's bad news for the robots
because so far we haven't been very good
at making AI that's good as a critical
reader of information this is actually a
serious problem and behind the scenes
people are working a bit on it
but it's a tricky problem because if you
won't have machine learning system to
take in all the data they are going to
get the biased data and probably right
now humans are much better at figuring
out wait a minute what's in it for a
pharma company to tell me this to a
robot
it's not going to be that easy to figure
out that part however it might be
possible to get around but I do think
that fooling robots might actually
become a big business but-but-but-but
when they're fine okay but there is a
point here you know it isn't a case of
the robot taking in the literature
that's out there in the BMJ and the New
England Journal of Medicine
there's no point taking that in it's all
fake at the moment okay what what the
robot will do they learn that I should
listen to the person right in front of
me who's saying this is happening that
the New England Journal of Medicine
article says can't happen the robot will
learn to keep this person alive I need
to listen to the person forget the New
England Journal of Medicine article the
doctor isn't listening to you what
they're listening to is the manager that
says to them if you don't keep the
guidelines based on the New England
Journal of Medicine you will lose your
job that's what they're listening to
they're not listening to you well I'm
the robot won't lose a job so that's why
he will listen to you I think what we're
hearing here is very much a caricature
and I don't think it reflects many of
our own experiences of medicine and I'm
thinking here particularly of there's a
town up in the North called Todd Mullen
and it's famous perhaps most famous for
an organization called incredible edible
which grows
food all around the town and one of the
very nice things that happened when they
built a new doctor surgery in Todd
burden was they actually every plant in
the carpark is edible now it's not quite
true to say that the doctors say write
your prescription is to walk outside and
pick two apples off the tree but there's
certainly an element of that now I'm
talking to young doctors and young
doctors are saying to me we're not
getting enough training in nutrition
we're not getting enough training in
this holistic kind of approach but
they're critical of that and they're
going out and looking for the answers
and looking for alternative approaches
and that's what many not all but many
doctors are doing and you know I find it
hard to imagine a robot saying go out
and pick two apples off the tree okay so
let's move on to the second theme so you
had at the start that studies have shown
that doctors are only correct in 55% of
easy cases and 66% six not sixty six of
difficult ones now that's quite a
shocking statistic why do you think it
is that doctors failed to make the
correct diagnosis often and more
importantly could a I improve this
situation is there therefore a place in
medicine for as you say the meticulous
diagnostic skills that are allowed by
using things like big data and AI well
I'll start off with you the problem here
I would suggest is not medicine
the problem is science and our level of
understanding of the working of the
human body to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit a IDOT
TV for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas